[Music]
let's go to i don't know if there's a
listener named jack that'd be cool we
are back
dennis and
i don't know that's our two listeners
dennis and jack i just made this weird
for dennis and jack out there hey dennis
and jack if you're listening
we're watching you all right let's go to
marie in harrisburg hey marie what's
going on
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you
um i'm getting there getting there
what's going on yes
um i had called in um a couple weeks ago
regarding my daughter um and
sixteen-year-old daughter
who was inpatient
at the hospital due to a suicide attempt
and we were waiting to find a inpatient
facility for her
um and you had helped me
kind of walk through that and what to
look for and who to ask and
screw up that helped a lot okay no no it
helped a lot i appreciate it i was
hoping you weren't calling me to say
like and you ruined everything all right
good
no
um
she is coming home from the facility
tomorrow um so that's exciting and we're
looking forward to having her home
but i know there's a lot of work that
we're going to be getting started on
two days ago i received a phone call
randomly from a detective
um and i think the detective thought
that i was expecting the phone call or i
was given some kind of a warning but i
wasn't oh does she disclose abuse
yes she does oh man um
she told that um i wasn't given any
details from the detective just that
there was abuse
um
and
then my mommy brain started going and i
called
a friend of hers
to see if she had ever mentioned
anything about it to try to get some
details
and um she did tell a friend um and the
friend told me that it was
her cousin
from the time she was about three until
she was nine
yeah
through very vivid details
um
hold on hold on hold on
do me a favor
take a real deep breath and hold it
and let it out
and take one more real real deep breath
and hold it
and then let it out
listen i'm so sorry
me too i'm so sorry that's your baby
girl and i'm so sorry
so um
before we go any further okay
you didn't screw anything up
yet
no
if you murder somebody yes
don't do that
okay all right so dad and you are
divorced
yes okay um
we've co-parented for the past
10-ish years no more than that probably
13 years
good or not good mature immature
[Applause]
it could be worse but it could be better
so it's not horrible okay
it's functioning um yes
open communication okay all that jazz is
good um
it's like my 2006 truck it works it gets
me to work but man but it's ugly
that was rude but you're correct
yeah i may or may not have all of my
headlights working yes okay right right
um
so after i got the phone with the
detective um i immediately called her
dead and
um just gave him the overview that i had
and then after i talked to
my daughter's friend i then called her
dad back and explained what more i had
been told
the cousin is on the dad's side of the
family okay
um lived with them for a period of time
and
dad is insistent that there's no way
this happened and she's lying okay
i don't think my daughter even knows
that we know
okay
um
and i'm not sure how to handle any of
this with her coming home tomorrow
before say
i i i don't even know what to say to her
like i don't know if i start the
conversation if i wait for the
conversation i don't know how to live in
the same house with her without having
the conversation though
um
and then do i prepare her
for the conversation with her dad
i i i don't know how to do any of this
oh man well number one thank you for
your trust
uh what a nightmare of a situation for
any parent at any time and any place um
okay so before there is number one
um
the detective called you
so
let me just back out number one secrets
drown people
so
secrets are no good
so yes we'll have to have conversations
yes we'll have to um
get into this and um ignoring it or just
letting her come home and like oh just
let her bring it up on her own time
can't do that okay
so keep that one that one
um that one put a pin in that note
secrets drown people
um she's been keeping these secrets for
a long long long time
the second thing is
if there's
when she's discharged from the hospital
there should be some sort of
parent meeting with the social worker
and with the counselor a psychologist of
some sort is that happening tomorrow
we've already had that and they said
nothing
okay
the
um
the only
how old is she
16. okay so
sometimes in these clinical contexts
they will make agreements with the kids
when they're trying to work through
trauma with them
the reality is and i don't know every
state i know the states i've been in and
looked at licensure and has been a
professor and things like that
when you are when your child goes to
counseling the parent is technically the
client
meaning you have access to all records
all things discussed you have access to
everything
i can't imagine
a social worker not disclosing this
that's
bonkers to me
i know in the state of pennsylvania
where i'm located
mental health records are sealed without
approval at the age of 14. so i don't
think unless my daughter were to give
permission that they can tell me
ah jeez okay
so
then here's the question here's a phone
call you make at eight a.m tomorrow
morning
okay you call the social worker and say
i have been contacted by a detective
um i have talked to my daughter tell her
everything my daughter's friends okay
she's coming home i have active
knowledge of a family member who's um
done these things
and we need to circle up and have that
conversation
and really put the social worker on the
defensive now probably what she will do
or he will do
and this is their licenses isn't them
being evil they're doing what their what
their job is what their licensure
requires
is
i need to have a conversation with
my client
and let them know
and um
my guess is the young girl is ashamed
scared frightened that it's not a
statement on you that's a statement of a
scared child
and um
my guess is
she was asked and said i don't want to
tell anybody anything
and because she's a minor
i think man even even not even minors
anymore these these laws are changing so
fast in such really remarkable honest
awesome ways
um but somebody had to report it to the
detective and the detective has
different rules than mental health
providers and so they have to contact
parents with a minor
all to say is going to get messy you're
going to have to be a bearer of a mom
and
bear meaning you got to go to war on
behalf of your daughter and the war here
is we all have to be in a room
communicating the same language
that's what the goal here is
if the social worker says the counselor
says i can't talk about it
then the conversation with your daughter
when she gets home
is um
lots of really
if she if she will again this is all pie
in the sky
um
less conversations for the first day or
so but
lots of hand holding can we just watch a
show can we watch a movie together will
you cuddle with me will she do that
yeah okay yeah
what we're doing is we're looking to
establish physical safety first
okay all right and that's gonna come
through high touch high hugs hand holds
hugs hey will you sit by me whatever her
favorite food is let's just create a
safe place here at home
okay and if there is a
if there is a friend if there is a is
there another adult she trusts or
something at some point very soon you'll
have to have that conversation
and it would go something like this
i got a call from a detective
and i learned some really troubling
heartbreaking things about how somebody
hurt you in the past
and i'm so so sorry and i also want to
honor the fact that you don't you're not
ready to talk to me about it
i want you to know that uh and does that
mean so i don't want you to put her in a
position where she goes on the defensive
again because she will
but i just want you to let her know i
know and when you're ready i'm ready to
have this conversation and then let her
know in the meantime and this is the
magic
in the meantime
i'm gonna go i have to go on the
offensive
because there's somebody out there that
hurt kids
that makes sense so it's letting a kid
know you can so what this sexual abuse
does is it takes control away from a kid
right
and the worst thing we can do to a kid
is to bring them back in a room in an
attempt to help them we take control
back from them again they feel out of
control and unrooted again
and
i have to make sure that this person who
did this never does this again
so when you're ready to talk to me i am
here i love you if you have any personal
experience with this and you can connect
in any way that this is the moment to be
vulnerable
um
if you haven't don't lie right don't
make something up right um here is the
the second cornerstone to put a pin in
number one secrets drown
number two
you have to believe your daughter
yes until you have every evidence in
front of you until you're holding
something that's that says she's not
telling the truth
and
i i
i understand your husband's fear and oh
my gosh what's gonna do the family and i
understand that dead
that domino
you gotta believe your daughter
you gotta believe your daughter
and
the way we show our kids that we believe
them is we call the police we don't say
things like well let's just talk about
it and
you know we call the police and we work
openly with the police we call the
school counselor we call somebody that
we're going to work with we let them
know
i'm working on your behalf even if their
16 year old little brain says i want to
keep this quiet
and it's so you hear the delicate
balance that i'm saying here
they get to wait to tell their story
but mom's going to work on your behalf
because i love you and my job is to keep
you safe i'm your parent yeah and i'm
not going to let that little scumbag
piece of trash that hurts you
i don't call them a piece of trash that
was that wasn't cool i don't i'm not
going to let that happen on my watch
anymore right does that make sense to
see that balance i'm we're in i know in
real time with a real human and a real
kid right in front of you this whole
thing's going to be feel wonky and
wobbly
and you may have to go back and say i
should have said it like this and i'm
sorry and i'm just so glad you're home
maybe some walking it back all that to
say is
physical safety
lots of touch moms on your side
hey and mom knows
yeah and when you're ready i'm here okay
but i'm going to work
yeah and
um
at the same time be graceful with your
husband at the same time say no sir this
is our daughter and we're going to
believe it and we're going to
ex-husbands
you call that up quick xxx good job
um
i get the fear it's unacceptable
he's gonna believe his daughter
yeah
and if he's not um then he needs to
understand that
these are these are ramifications that
go through generations
i finally told that i wasn't okay and he
believed that guy not me
yeah
and that's hard and messy and gross and
weird and awful but here we go
um is the detective gonna do like a
forensic interview with her and go
through that process
yes but i have no idea when
when i spoke with a detective she was
just trying to get
the jurisdiction of where
it was reported that this happened
um which was a very odd conversation
we're not we're talking about where it
happened we're not talking it just it
was it was it was a hard conversation
yes it could be surreal um
yeah yeah um but she really didn't give
me any information other than you'll be
hearing from the police at some point
okay and i've been waiting for that
phone call and i have no idea when
that's coming
do yourself a favor and your heart and
soul a favor
be ready for that call
but don't wait for it every second
you're going to make yourself crazy
right
when i sit down with my daughter and
have a conversation
do we
do i then call the police
if she wants
if she would want to talk to them do we
call them do
we just continue to wait to hear from
them like i don't know
i don't know how to handle that every
yeah if she's ready to talk then yeah
you call in everybody absolutely 100. if
she says i'm ready to talk my guess is
she won't my guess is she went and had
to talk about it a lot and
therapy she's going to be embarrassed
that she cost all this stuff she's going
to want to know about the expense of it
all dad's going to bring up expense this
is really expensive i hope that he's
gonna say stuff like that because he's
nervous enough to say
um
the main thing is reestablishing
connection here
if she said and how do you balance and
this is a hard balance that every
parent's got to deal with how do you
balance
i want to teach you and honor you and
your autonomy
and i got to do what i got to do because
i'm your parent
you know so
she may get sit down with the detective
and say nothing
i'm not going to talk to you
the story that will remain with her is
mom called the police mom got me help
right okay and so
we want that established and
you can encourage her to talk to the
police you can
but at the end of the day you can't make
her or you end up forcing her in some
sort of the arc is becomes really hard
and i've seen this happen over and over
you will tell them everything
well now suddenly i've taken from you
again
and that's the great fear when
somebody's been abused right is that
they were they were part of them was
stolen
and they were right back in the same
place
so i talked with a friend the other day
and she put it that this is her story
and i need to let her tell it correct
and
she's your daughter and it's time for
mama
to get after
it's both hand
and when either parent plays it on
either side when a parent tries to take
over their kid's life and say you're
going to do this you're going to do this
you're going to do this
it's a re-traumatization process not
always but often or when they just take
their foot off the brakes and they just
say she's just not ready she's 16.
you know what i mean like there's a
reason we don't let her buy beer because
her brain's not fully formed yet right
there's a reason we don't let her so
mom is supposed to advocate dad is
supposed to go to war everybody's
supposed to get involved to protect my
daughter
and these are the moments these these
pivotal moments when
maybe the right things aren't said but
the kid your child will remember mom had
my back mom was there by me okay and
let's let's play the other side of this
out
the worst case scenario is this actually
happened
that's the worst case scenario
it's also really gonna be a mess if she
let's say she didn't make all this up
we will get there if we ever get there
but i'm gonna default to believe in my
kid until i know otherwise yeah
even if that means we get to the end and
the detective says i don't have anything
that i can prosecute here i don't have
any text messages i don't i don't have
anything the stories whatever
she'll know mom mom had my back
yeah and i think it's worth telling your
ex-husband this is a pivotal moment in
your daughter's life when she came to us
with something
she reached out there's been some very
colorful conversations i really have i'm
sure there have been i'm sure there have
yeah um
just remember secrets remember human
connection and remember believe your
daughter
okay and um if you have another woman
that you trust that your daughter trusts
it may be great to bring her in so i'm
going to leave you with this one really
incredible story
um
my friend and it's something that i'll
do with my kid 100
and i've encouraged people all over the
country to do this
two of my closest friends in the world
guys named michael and a guy named kevin
and then we have another friend who's a
doctor they went camping and they have
they had kids and it was one of those
you hear these now there's no ritual for
for
uh western teens um to transition from
being a child to like we're gonna start
treating you with with some
responsibility and as an adult right but
we don't have these moments these
markers anymore
so you hear about these things where you
take them out and you go on a camping
trip or something or a trip and unite
them you know like with a sword or
knighting or something like that
that's all fine whatever if that works
for you
they did something i've never heard
before and it was remarkable
they took um i think it was they took
their sons out maybe took out their
daughter too
and they were at x age right so i'm
making this up let's say they were
turning 15.
they my friend kevin sat down
and handed michael's son a card with his
name and number on it
and he said from this point forward i'm
not mr and he gave his last name he said
i'm kevin
i'm gonna start talking to you like this
and
you're gonna call me kevin and
here's my promise
in the middle of the night dads aren't
always the right guy to call when you're
too drunk to drive home dads aren't
always respond to the best when you get
that call from jail i can't you can bail
me out so kevin looked at this his best
friend's son and said you call me
and i'll be there
and he said i will sit on your side of
the table when we talk to your dad
it's not we're getting we have to have
this conversation you went to jail right
or you got arrested or whatever
but i'll sit on your side
and it was twofold number one it was
a demonstration to a young person here's
what friendship looks like even when
you're old
and most importantly some kids can't
talk to their parents this person's safe
and so if you have a woman two women two
three women who maybe have experience
here have had a history of abuse and
have are older now and have have healed
and are still healing
anybody in your life that you trust that
you bring into your daughter's life and
it's almost a passing of a torch i know
that i'm your mom and i know that i can
be loud and bonkers and whatever
she's safe and i want you to know if you
don't feel like you can talk to me you
can talk to her
and have that does that make sense so
there's almost there's this yeah not
almost there is a
there is a you're broadening your
daughter's safety circle
you're you're widening her debt
and
man
could be a really extraordinary gift for
your daughter
thank you for that call marie thank you
for calling back and updating us all on
the situation i'm heartbroken i'm glad
she's coming home i'm glad that she is
still with us i'm glad she is on the
road to wellness and
i'm glad that she felt safe enough to
talk about this i'm heartbroken at what
she admitted
but
now we know now we know
and now
the community's going to rally around
her starting with you she's lucky lucky
lucky to have you as her mom
we're with you holler back at us after
in a few weeks let us know how things
are going and we'd love to have you back
on the show marie thank you so much